when it comes to paid marketing you're
gonna want to give it some extra thought
and consider a few things before going
out there and paying to acquire new
customers after all we are startup so we
want to spend our money wisely now if
you want to make sure your growth is
sustainable and your money is well-spent
you want to keep in mind a few different
metrics
starting with ARP you or your average
revenue per customer the LTV or lifetime
value per customer and the CPA cost per
acquisition now you want to think about
how much money you're willing to spend
per customer to get them in the door so
these are the things you need to
consider to determine this
so there's your ARP you your average
revenue per user so how much money are
you gonna make per a given customer over
a certain time frame knowing your ARP
you and your retention rate so how long
you're keeping your customers with you
can help you calculate your lifetime
value or LTV your LTV is the amount of
money you're likely to make from a given
customer over the time that they're
affiliated with your company okay let's
take the lifetime value of a gym member
for example so let's say the member
spends $20 a month over three years on
their membership so that's $20 a month
for 12 months for three years giving you
a total lifetime value of seven hundred
and twenty dollars for that one customer
in total revenue about $240 per year now
for startups who haven't acquired any
customers yet determining your LTV is
nearly impossible to do but since it's
so helpful in helping you define your
goals and setting a baseline it's really
worth an effort to at least estimate it
based on the number of transactions a
given customer will make over a month or
even over a year okay let's take a
barque minute for example we charge $20
a month as a fee for sitters to be
listed on our site and every time they
get a sitting job we get 15% of what
they're charging which averages out to
be around 15 dollars per month and most
sitters stay with us for about 24 months
so this makes their lifetime value 840
dollars your LTV an average revenue per
user it's going to help drive how much
you're willing to spend to get new
customers so if our cost per acquisition
is too close to our lifetime value or
average revenue per user then we're
doing something wrong however if our
cost-per-acquisition is $70 per sitter
we're profiting about 770 dollars per
sitter we have on our site this would
make our average revenue per user higher
than how much it costs us to gain that
user which is really what your goal is
one thing I want to point out is that
you should be looking at your LTV or ARP
you per segment think back to market
segmentation about this that way you can
determine how much you can pay to
acquire different users from different
segments for example if we decide to
have our dog owners pay a $50 monthly
fee and then we get 15% of all of their
bookings which average out to about
$22.50 a month and they stay with us for
three years we're looking at an LTV of
two thousand six hundred and ten dollars
so we know we can spend more to gain dog
owners because their lifetime value is
significantly higher than the lifetime
value of dog sitters now if your company
has different subscriptions you may see
that people in one subscription group
have a much lower lifetime value than
somebody from another subscription group
that'll help you determine how much you
want to spend on getting people into
different subscription tiers for example
if people in the lowest paying
subscription don't stay with you as long
you're not going to want to spend as
much to acquire them as a customer
however if people in say your platinum
level stay with you for a long time and
spend a ton of money with you you can be
willing to spend a little bit more to
acquire that customer now having said
that our company is a marketplace so in
order to maintain this healthy
marketplace we have to ensure both
supply and demand
so sometimes we may need to spend more
on sitters to sustain our supply or else
the company would fail because being a
company that offers a babysat your dog
without people to actually babysit the
dog wouldn't work out too well so these
metrics are valid across online customer
acquisition channels and they're just
the beginning you can also consider
conversions so how many people actually
become customers
bounce rates for emails and even traffic
from specific channels and much more
we'll talk more about a few of these
during this lesson and the next so let's
hear from tally about her advice on paid
marketing and then we'll start talking
about our first channel SEM or search
engine marketing